moi je vous rappelle moi j'avais une
technique moi avec ma meuf c'était en
fait à chaque fois que j'avais d'autres
9 à mettre sur mon sang mon répertoire
avec ce métier que des trucs sncf
bien sûr je vais très
mal alors comme ça les
[Applaudissements]
séries un chéri j'ai des amis c'est très
bien que aulas est très bien maintenant
de tickets que je dépense par an voilà
seul sac à dos clientèle non mais voilà
mais où est ce que vous avez déjà fait
des trucs avec votre portable pour
essayer de ne pas vous faire griller je
me tourne vers bien sûr si aly fall
messianistes téléphone compris on
l'appelle les deux teams etienne et les
3t avec un voile à l'est le groupe vial
et doté oui mais moi j'ai demeure qui
s'appelle cyril hanouna dans mon
portable non c'est par ici il vous
envoyer un texto un jour
non mais c'est sûr c'est vrai alors
julien ne vous savez pas le nombre moi
tous mes copains c'est ça qui roulent
tous mes copains qui veulent avoir des
bail avec des meufs qu'est ce qu'ils
font à la meuf il met cyril hanouna j'ai
toujours ce n'est pas la première fois
que je sais pas pourquoi vous voulez
vous êtes absolument syrie damas écoutez
je ne suis pas votre jouet
et donc pas être conservé dans mon cas
il ya moi ouais ah oui et donc vous vous
aurez voilà il faut pas jouer on a peur
qu'un jour votre portable sur elle et
c'est que des mecs disent tout
non mais je change de code toutes les
semaines d'accord les conseillers et
votre main vous dit pas c'est bizarre
qui chante le code toutes les semaines
bah le sait enfin y'a un truc alors je
vous dire il ya un truc qui ne trompent
pas ouais c'est le restaurant avec votre
make that most si votre mec mais le
reste
mais vous n'y c'est sûr elle est clair
et net il ya un autre bail aussi c'est
quand votre note vous dit cherry est ce
que tu peux passer ton tel je vais faire
des pâtes riz et youtube tout arrêter
avec ces
insupportables
oui elle a pa ta meuf elle à l'hôtel
regardes tu veux faire des photos à
lille fait à fait ma meuf qui vous faire
des deux poteaux bon allez qui
s'installent ici
tu connais pas va pas lâcher comme ça à
l'estomac elle fait comme l'a dit allez
ça suffit ça suffit c'est devenu
insupportable avec ses réseaux sociaux
moi je n'en peux plus oui merci elle dit
j'ai un problème j'ai plus de batterie
ce que tu peux me passer ton téléphone
parce que sa ferrari au fresnoy n'ya
alors le pire le pire je vous le dis ce
que c'est c'est les enfants qui tu leur
dis ouais tu vas mélanie oui et donc
tapé la mère femme amère donc nous leur
mamie et tu vois les enfants tu voi
enfants partir
watts est assis avec ta meuf et tu vois
ton fils partir lino
lâche maintenant c'est bon ça va ça va
cinq minutes non mais c'est vrai
ça très bon ça c'est vrai et ouais et
caen et quand amos harel taudis est
alors le pire le pire mois je veux
raconter une histoire mais sans haie
mais voilà c'était j'étais qu'une autre
9 longtemps je calcule mafia longtemps
racontez pas ivre il est je suis avec un
copain
et je l'appelle avant et je lui dis
ouais tu sais que j'ai rendez vous avec
nathalie judy mais attention ne
m'appelle pas là parce que là là je vais
être avec ma meuf et je vais t'en
bluetooth d'accord alors oui on
m'appelle surtout pas d'accord on dit
d'accord d'accord d'accord
ça pas failli je suis dans la voiture je
suis avec ma main je vois le numéro du
gars à tricher
c'est pas un abruti là ça résonne dans
toute la voiture
tu appuies ça sonne je réponds et là on
entend revenir alors tu la pêche au
labeur
il à côté et tu précédent
outil
la
trompette et pas l'abruti beaucoup
tombent à plat toute façon quel abruti
et suscite
évidemment pas du tout à la fusion
c'était une histoire ça ça date d'il ya
vingt ans je rigole pas les goûts tous
les bars soirées what you non non non
non non non non à bessèges et magali
mort d'hakim a fait un truc comme ça
j'étais macquart veille avec maggie
grave alors j'étais un week-end
romantique avec quelqu'un donc j'ai
changé avec magali tu es mon ami par
paroisse de sap est dit tu fais quoi je
dis bah je suis avec une amie un
week-end romantique elle m'envoie un
vocal jeunes écoutant haut parleurs sous
la voiture jeudi a pas de conneries
dedans et 10 mai toi tu fais quoi dans
ta vie à part ken
et magali ça c'est rattrapable ouais
c'est pas gagné difficilement c'est
magali bertin
alors vous est-ce que vous avez des
histoires il paraît qu'un jour il ya un
pigeon voyageur
guitare et non mais je vous avais déjà
eu des histoires comme ça vous j'aurais
pu me marier nul ton tout ce qui est
technique donc là je suis tranquille il
ira jamais regardé dans mon iphone
allait de toute façon mensuelle merci on
va prendre téléphone c'est une
catastrophe parce que c'est vrai qu'à un
moment j'étais j'ai complètement changé
à maman j'étais un peu volage j'avoue
c'est pas marqué que toute cette
histoire démarre mal
mais c'est vrai m'attend je suis
rapprochables et donc je vais passer mon
célibataire non maintenant je suis à
moitié ou l'a déjà
aujourd'hui la au jour j à moitié basse
et maintenant je vous avais une partie
de vous avec la personne et je suis pas
célibataire
c'est très près c'est très frais ça date
de trois jours
non je suis pas du tout célibataire
c'est le montant que ça ne marche pas
célibataire et donc à l'époque j'étais
un peu volage à passer mon temps à
supprimer les conversations et a bloqué
les personnes pour paquebots pas risquer
jetons qu'on téléphone sonne au resto
etc donc je passais mes journées à
supprimer b bloqué bloqué supprimer
c'est un enfer verte sur ton de trente
numéros fois trois opérations sur 90
opérations par jour pour bloquer
développer je vois que ça me fait chier
c'est dit non non non vous alors vous
jean michel maire on s'attendait à mieux
quand même franchement j'en ai humé vous
concerne et je vais pas me raconter
non je plaisante
audrey vaudrait voilà alors moi je me
bloque je verrai mon téléphone je change
de nos codes tous les toute la semaine
et je le retourne aussi
[Applaudissements]
à
bon compte mais ce petit témoignage
tous demandé à siné nom
et sans rigoler à
défaut oui ici oui mais ici à la
fidélité à fidélité c'est ça qui doit la
ramener quelque chose alors déjà les
mêmes on évite en
ajoutant pour moi c'est monsieur
monsieur ah oui bonjour mathieu
je joue je téléphone c'est quoi le
téléphone c'est le premier aveux
d'infidélité tous ici la retourne chez
thomas shine à moi j'ai été totalement
tranquille j'en compte des visiteurs
mais sûr que je tends couple j'aurai
beau jeune et quand tout ça n'existe
plus j'ai été totalement tranquille le
jour où justement qu'est ce que j'ai
fait j'ai compris que l'autre il fallait
le rassurer donc mon téléphone portable
pas de code il est tout le temps là il
est disponible la personne peut le
prendre regarder dedans échanges et n'y
a rien dedans y'a pas de puce soc n'y a
rien dedans du coup la loue l'autre est
persuadé que si ton téléphone n'y a pas
de code et qui peut regarder c'est vrai
tu es totalement totalement clean dallas
est en réalité moi ma façon de
communiquer c'était bien une fausse
adresse mail et via un ordinateur tout
simplement le communiqué par mail donc
le téléphone c'était vraiment avec ça
j'étais tranquille et je n'ai jamais été
aussi tranquille c'est le téléphone qui
vous tue tous si tu veux être infidèle
et si tu veux être une mauvaise personne
montre que ton téléphone est clean était
nickel
qui s'affolent
verdez est extrêmement fidèle de riz le
noël bien sûr j'avais eu des problèmes
moi j'avais été piquées sur minitel est
belle alors là on apprend qu'une wire
d'ailleurs on avec l'autorisation du
blues avaient l'écoutent oui
les coûts là du coup
j'ai beaucoup aimé la sur les bail de
deux ans tu parlais j'étais pas bien lie
claude tous âges étaient pas là parce
qu'avec des sites de rencontres il avait
notamment 36 15 aline on peut le dire
maintenant ça a disparu tout ça ou la
visite une bonne heure 36 15 al hiloueh
et j'étais une des égéries du site parce
que c'est vrai qu'à un moment je me
connectais beaucoup
graphique c'est quoi et donc c'était un
site de rencontre quand un citoyen ou
les olé de rencontres j'avoue gendarme
est plus lourd aux non adhérents contre
ce n'est pas pour eux se verrait lui
comment ça va non non je dois pour ken
suire werder salut elle était l'égérie
d'un psy week-end à tel point qu en
titane égérie gt oui oui car nous
extorquer tuerie
[Rires]
les autres
c'est fais toi les héritages ratatat a
donc un petit mot oui ou non c'est à
dire que genre pour vendre le site est
pour dire venez père des rencontres
c'était toi les génies c'est à dire que
tu as le passé beaucoup de temps à me
fait donc tout avait été tellement les
gerry's j'en ai gagné tellement d'heures
de connexion je leur avais fait gagné
tellement d'argent qui s'aiment avait
appelé à la maison il avait eu mon
numéro il avait appelé à la maison et à
l'époque j'étais en couple il était une
fin de couple monsieur donc il était
tombé sur madame vous êtes notre
monsieur fallait
parce que c'était perdu
entre nous tu joueras couture fait le
lien il avait fait le lien à l'époque
par l'abonnement et donc il avait dit
voilà ce numéro là vous avez été celui
du mois qui a fait tant d'heures de
connexion nous vous invitons à venir
chez nous et c'était dans les locaux
d'un jour n'est qu'ils s'appellent
nouvel observateur c'était un voilà qui
gérait sa et donc j'avais été invité
comme égérie mais ça avait fini de brisé
mon couple ah ouais bah oui et vous êtes
à l'écart et la soirée bien sûr ah ouais
ça va oui je vous invite à lui rien ne
vous arrête non mais j'étais une figure
de proue de 36 15 à ligéria vous
maintenant c'est beau ça fait 1 fermé
quelques temps après à bonn qui m'étonne
dans leur égérie évidemment faire douter
aujourd'hui termes tu peux vous n'avez
pas de doute là dessus en tout cas et
merci pour ces histoires girondine début
d'une histoire vous comme ça sur avec le
téléphone est non pas donc aussi quand
j'étais jeune en revanche rejeté mais au
moins j'étais n'avons pas tous
d'histoire
rester rieuse effectivement j'avais des
noms de code les tokyo new york hambourg
mini que tout ça
la
mégane tokyo et à tokyo qui
[Musique]
c'est incroyable cette za et oui vous
voulez réagir moi oui non non je moi
j'ai eu ça mais avec des lettres
évêque c'est beau ça cartonne on peut se
permettre c'était à l'époque on
s'envoyait beaucoup de moi et moi je
sorte avec un mec absolument splendide
un mètre 95 basketteurs gym aquagym 15
basket très très beau gilles et les
jeunes est un très très beau et un
manuel très très beau un espagnol qui
ressemble un peu à ringo qui voulait
absolument sortir
c'est comme okajima la marque voilà mes
plus beaux
voilà il était magnifique et donc comme
il l'avait la courtoisie beaucoup nous
draguer je me souviens j'aimerais bien
voir quand même sortir un peu une soirée
mais que ce mec pour voir ce que ça
donne donc évidemment j'ai fait un mot c
contient une copine pour qu'elle lui
donne évidemment elle l'a donné à celui
qui était à ce moment là avec moi
on va tirer comme un concitoyen
[Applaudissements]
l'histoire continue une musique
d'attenté
à ses basques et or aveugle en plus
[Applaudissements]
d'être toujours magnifique william l
vous vous dire voilà regarder
j'espère des mois sa famille sur le
braille